[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Smart
Lock for Passwords
is a great technology
that lets you
sign in only once across
all of your devices.
Today I'm meeting with Steven
Soneff of the Google Identity
Platform to learn more about it.
And Stephen, you're the product
manager for the Google Identity
Platform, right?
Sounds like you work on some
pretty cool technologies.
STEVEN SONEFF:
Yeah that's right.
So I'm product manager for
all of our APIs and services
that we provide to third
parties around security
and authentication, basically
knowing who their users are
and helping them get
signed in and signed up
as easily as possible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Important job.
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So I know you
wrote this blog post recently
about Smart Lock for Passwords.
Could you tell us a little bit
about that, and what it is,
and what's so great about it?
STEVEN SONEFF: Sure.
So Smart Lock is one
of our recent additions
to the set of APIs we offer.
It came out last
year at Google I/O,
basically functionality
to save and retrieve
information about how people
sign in to a third-party app.
So if you use an
app like Netflix,
you can save your log in
information either from Chrome,
if you've saved
your password there,
or next time you
sign into the app.
And then retrieve
it when you come
back so that if you
have a new phone,
you don't have to remember that
username or password anywhere.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
And so if I've
signed in in Chrome,
it will remember it when
I sign in on my phone?
STEVEN SONEFF: Exactly.
So any information
you save with Google
can help you sign in
as easily as possible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now I see you have a
demo lined up there.
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, so let's
actually see how it works.
So typically, when
you're trying to log
into an app like Netflix, you'll
see a username and password
field like that.
You have to enter your
username, your password.
You have to remember
what those are,
which can be pretty tricky
if you signed up a year ago.
But now the idea
is that if you're
using one of the Smart Lock
APIs, you can restart the app.
Pretend this is a
brand-new install now.
And instead of having to
reenter that information,
you see this screen,
which is basically
explaining to the user their
saved information has been used
to help log them in,
even automatically,
without ever having to
remember what that username
and password is.
And with that, you're in.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really neat.
Like you can see kids out there.
So if I'm sharing an
account with my kids,
I can do that also?
STEVEN SONEFF: Exactly.
So yeah, it will work
for anyone who has
access to that Google account.
So that if you've got
even a shared device,
it will be a completely
seamless experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And now I heard you're also
working on tokenizing this
so that it's your actual Google
Account on the devices used.
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, so
you mentioned the blog post
that we had recently.
And so the blog post talks about
not just saving and retrieving
things like passwords, but
actually going beyond passwords
and going over to
token-based authentication.
That if you basically use
something like the Gmail
address on your
device as the account
for your third-party
apps or your sites,
that we can retrieve
information about that
when you're signed in on this
device with that account.
And if you're already
signed in, then there's
no need to enter
passwords manually
to your third-party apps.
They can check that
it's actually you
and save the password entry,
and maybe even sign you up
with just one tap.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really cool.
Now if I'm a developer, if I'm
building an app like this one
that you just showed
me, what kind of things
do I need to do to take
advantage of the Smart Lock
for Passwords?
STEVEN SONEFF: So starting
point is just checking out
developers.google.com/identity
and going into the Smart Lock
section there.
And what you'll see is that
it's a pretty simple interface.
You can save information and
you can retrieve information.
There's an additional
API method to show
a picker, like an email picker
that can help fill a sign up
form really easily.
With one tap you'll get
name and picture and email
address all filled in.
And then if you can
save that information,
even use the token to skip
things like email verification
or password entry.
It could make it a very
smooth experience in your app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
not just smooth, right?
It can also help
make it more secure?
Because I know when I've
gone on to various sites
or various apps and I need
to sign up, and sometimes
there's a lot of information
that I need to put in.
But if they were implementing
something like this,
they can get the best
of knowing that I
am who I say that I
am when I sign up,
but I'm also more secure
and not giving out
personal information
to a third-party when
I don't need to.
Is that right?
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, exactly.
So we're really moving toward
this model of basically only
providing the essential
information at the time
that someone is
signing up, and trying
to ask for more information
later, kind of in context
when it's most relevant,
so the user has the most
control over what
they're providing
to the third-party apps.
When it is provided,
we're hoping
to provide it in the form
of these tokens, which
can be verified
and authenticated,
and ensuring that it's only that
person and not just somebody
who knows the password who's
trying to access the account.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And then
also if the particular app
needs to do things that require
incremental authorization,
like I don't know,
accessing my Drive
or Calendar, that's something
that the API also offers,
right?
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah,
so that's actually
offered as part of a
broader set of APIs
around logging in
with Google Services.
In the same place,
developers.google.com/identity,
check out how you can integrate
all the Google APIs that are
out there into your
app or services.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we
found-- I don't remember
the exact figures right now.
Maybe you do.
But we found that when
people implement auth
like this instead of
rolling their own auth,
that the actual user retention
is much greater, right?
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah.
So typically what we found
in some of the studies
we've done is that if someone
sees a sign in screen,
in the order of half of people
will not complete it or not
complete it correctly, anything
from a forgotten password
to creating a duplicate account.
And by saving this information
so that when they come back,
you can really
reduce those errors
and make it much more impactful,
that all the downloads that you
get on your app can
be made to good use.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So by implementing this
properly, for users
it's more secure and
it's more convenient.
And then for developers
it also helps
you retain your users, right?
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, exactly.
The Netflix example,
we did a case study
with them recently
saying that in the order
of 20% of their cost for
support about password
recoveries and account
recoveries has been--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
Just wiped out.
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, exactly,
reduced by using these APIs.
And looks promising
for the future,
that it could be even better
with things like tokens.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Pretty cool.
So to get started,
developers.google.com/identity.
STEVEN SONEFF: Yep.
That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, awesome.
Well, thank you, Steven.
STEVEN SONEFF: Well,
thank you, Lawrence.
And I have something for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, swag.
I always love swag.
STEVEN SONEFF: You've been
doing all of this great work
recently with the Identity team,
we have here a hoodie for you
from the Google Authentication
and Security team.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Google
Authentication, nice.
Well, thank you, Steven.
I'll be sure to wear this at
my next Google [? Hangout. ?]
So thanks a lot, Steven.
I really appreciate the
time that you spent with us.
And if you've got
any questions for us,
just please leave them
below and check out
the links in the description.